[Music]
[Applause]
ran ER Locker the Hall of Famer was with
the Bears for 13 Seasons former
Defensive Player of the Year joining us
on behalf of ludex the fastest and most
accurate Sports and trading card scanner
app you take a picture identify get the
Cards value instantly and you can
download it for free you spell it lud ex
great to see you again in we talked
about this I don't know if it was last
year trying to figure out what you have
in your attic you know when Mom says I'm
going to throw those out know they're
valuable now we have an opportunity to
figure out how valuable your show is a
reason why they did the app they heard
on your show so they made the app up
seriously kidding no they they heard
someone I think was it fry talking about
it on your show one day no no no it had
to be somebody intelligent so you
definitely you then yeah so I guess I
heard you talking about it and they were
in the process of coming up with the app
and then you guys talked about it oh did
you hear that proba they were in the
process of coming up with steal your IDE
we could share Bri yeah we could share
perfect you wouldn't be the first to
steal something from this sure all of
your viewers yes you have our blessing
there thank you um when's the last time
you hit somebody that guy right there
Paulie Paulie that I mean that's a while
ago at the super 2018 right was that in
Atlanta yeah yeah I have I mean I don't
I pulled my hamstring playing softball
about seven years ago that's the last
time I ran and I wasn't full speed uh
now I just ride my bike that's it yeah
but do you miss that contact I don't
miss contact no hell no I mean gosh you
I mean well the game's different now
there's not as much contact as there was
back when I played but um I don't miss
getting hit my son plays High School
football so I get a chance to watch him
play and see how he feels after game so
I'm good but I would think you would
just want that feeling of hitting
somebody not being hit but hitting
somebody yeah I I mean I I don't think
about it like that because there's
repercussions to both sides of it you
know if you're hitting someone you're
still going to take a little bit of the
brunt but yeah I don't miss it at all
Dan I don't I don't I don't cover
nothing what happened to
football safe you know I mean the rules
had to change right you want players
well they get they want the quarterbacks
to play longer they want the receivers
to play longer running backs they don't
care about and defensive players they
don't care about but they want the QBs
and receivers to play longer right okay
but and score points was it yeah more
importantly was it starting to change
while you were still playing did you get
a sense that they were starting to
protect the quarterback even more so you
know I I think it's always it's been
evolving since my since I came into the
league in 2000 um but yeah I mean they
got to protect them you know that's
where all the money's spent that's where
the the fans want to see points scored
as you as you said earlier but yeah I
don't I don't know man it's just it's
been evolving over the last 15 20 years
and now it's just it is what it is now I
can't stand it when the guys get thrown
into the quarterback from an offensive
lineman they call roughing the passer
for GU hitting him in the knee but he
got thrown into the
quarterback how would you have to change
your game if you played now I don't
think I would you know maybe maybe some
some uh launch angles you know when want
to go up to hit a guy but those things
you can't change in a split second you
know so those are going to happen and
they still happen but I don't think my
game would would have to change much at
all would you be a linebacker or an edge
rusher I can't rush The Edge I be a
linebacker I don't like dealing with
offensive tackles those guys are really
big so Micah Parson I heard you talking
earlier um Bosa those guys are
definitely Edge rushers mik can do
anything he could probably pay safety
but um now they're interchangeable they
just get up there and and beat up the
lineman but uh Ray Lewis wouldn't be an
edge rusher no Ray Ray was a midle
linebacker for sure yeah well my body
type's different than Ray right mine six
I could body type wise I could probably
play defensive end or or Edge rusher but
those guys are just different like
mentally I don't think I have that
mentality who would you like to face now
quarterback wise oh here we go um let's
see are you are you trying to make make
someone look good like guys that we
could actually have success against yeah
like who who would you look forward to
facing and then maybe it's a different
answer of that's kind of a setup though
because then you're going to say
someone's not playing very well okay
well you might all right MC Jones you'd
like sorry I like ma but he's having a
tough year okay but what would you do
with somebody like that who doesn't have
great weapons and so how do you make him
play Under Your Hands we would make them
throw the football um but all we ran was
cover too no matter what the love he put
us in a seven-man front our defensive
line controll the line of scrimmage and
we just run to the football but pass
wise I mean it'd be hard to not play man
I think versus them because we think our
DBS are better than their receivers how
would you do against Mahomes oh he's
good um that that we run we run cover
too and you got Kelsey in there as well
we would run cover twoo out probably 75
80% of the time against him we wouldn't
we want to be manned up because he's
going to create separation for his
receivers but but are you are you
responsible for Kelsey certain players I
would be yeah ver in cover two there's a
lot of times that would be but it's
never a man situation unless he's going
down the middle then I'd be locked up on
him but but uh for the most part we'd be
just play cover two that's why we're so
good because we can play cover two in
every situation best tight end you ever
faced ever faced probably Tony Tony
Gonzalez what was about him that made
him he could he was big he could run he
could catch um he was physical uh you
know also as good as uh Antonio Gates
was really good as well there in San
Diego big guy big guy yeah basketball
player playing football he he was solid
they're all good though you know
everyone you get there's a reason
they're in the NFL they're really good
football players is there a a tackle
that you missed going after a
quarterback that you think
about not no not the Brady one oh the
another one um well that was
embarrassing well look Brady doesn't get
the do for how fast he is y people don't
understand he not fast I put him like
Vic Lamar Jackson like he's in that he's
he's in that category people don't
understand now that's the one because
I'll tell you why that one pisses me off
because it was it was third and five and
they or maybe third and six and they
were in the red zone and they got the
first down they scored a touchdown a
couple plays later so that's the one
that hurt me cuz if I tackle them it's
either fourth and five or whatever and
they're probably kicking a field goal we
lose the game 1713 boom there you go
yeah thanks for bringing man no we
talking about com on your show you got
these great little stats for me your
little facts I appreciate it Brady has
no Mobility I I disagree he has no moves
he had some moves that day he had some
moves that day that's his career
highlight run good job I I made Brady's
we're on the same draft class you know
it's nice I could I don't think he needs
my being on highlight films but yeah it
was a good run man I missed the tackle
but is there one that you were going in
for a sack that you think
about I don't know I mean sacks are like
bonuses right you're supp you know
you're supposed to make the play but um
I'm sure there's plenty I missed but
there I don't do you have one in mine is
that usually you have something you're
going to show video something no no no
no no no no no I like hey what about
this one though um no I uh not not off
the top of my head I can't think of any
that I miss sack wise uh I know I missed
one the playoffs versus Jake Del Al but
w got him so it didn't matter um the
ones that make me mad the ones that cost
our team like that one was third and
five like I said he got the first down
they scoring touchdown but um there's
plenty of times I miss tackles and got
ran over though if you want to bring
those up too you want to talk about some
of those I'm not going to bring up Drome
B what about Brandon Jacobs and Brandon
Jacob Jacobs just truck me in the
preseason one year uh there sure there's
other times too I've been ran over I got
ran over eighth grade really bad on the
punt
return and we have
highlight Brandon Jak
oh man when we saw him in person and I
go he looked like he could have been
ocura or Michael Strahan he might have
been bigger than Michael Str that's a
big man right there he had to be 265 or
270 running however fast he ran and I
tried to hit him full speed in the chest
coming sideways and it didn't work out
good for me uh Brian irocker joining us
in studio joining us on behalf of the
fastest and most accurate Sports and
trading card scanner app it's called
ludex LX LX I say lud something times do
those lud sounds cool yeah yeah not L
it's l x it's Lou I like that too ludex
l u DX take a picture identify get card
values instantly download for free if
the Bears have the number one pick they
should oh man uh it's kind of early to
tell but I mean it'd be hard to pass up
on well they just traded last year right
they may have the number one and two
pick from what I hear yeah and things
keep progressing the way they are or I
guess regressing the way they are um I
think you got to TP Caleb Williams okay
right yeah I mean the way he's played so
far his numbers his athletic ability way
he throws the football uh but depends on
how they value Justin as well you know
the last couple games looks a little
different okay right okay different are
you have you changed your opinion well
he has a great receiver in DJ Moore yeah
and they're getting him the football I
thought he could have had four or five
touchdowns last week DJ yeah he was
playing against a high school kid did
you see what he was doing to that corner
I mean he wasn't I'm just seeing DJ as a
man but you check in see if that DB was
a high was he legal was he over 18 I
mean he was just saying DJ was is a man
you know he he was having his way with
that guy but yeah I mean but then you
can I'm sure there's some linemen out
there as well if they have those two top
two three picks whatever you got to get
Marvin Harrison the Ohio State wide
receiver you got DJ Moore though you got
a guy you got number one no you could
never have enough receivers true very
true they got him um yeah I would I
would but you got to go I think dline
even if there's a pass rusher right
there as well I don't know I like what
Houston did last year by the way taking
CJ Sout and Anderson yeah that was
awesome they're both playing great this
year as well is there any bad blood left
over with anybody you played against
that if you saw
somebody no I don't think so I I didn't
really have bad bu play with guys either
you know you you don't you you're mad
you're not mad but when you're playing
you're competing and then when you see
them you know you see all these guys
when they see each other they're all
buddy buddies so it's the same way I
guess you're friends with them uh it's
good to see him again I just saw I was
just ass signing in Chicago last week
and I saw all the older guys than me
Marcus all Charles Haley uh just um
there's a bunch of old Bears there
Richard Dent was there just nice to see
they're a little bit older than me but
it's nice to see those guys and kind of
just listen to them talking till stories
Charles Haley is hilarious he is crazy
and hilarious yeah yeah he has some good
stories and he'll tell you all about him
too he's great I mean he he got me
corner for a little bit I saw Zach
Thomas about Zach's my guy Zach got in
the hall this year y finally finally um
he's still not very tall but he got in
he got in he deserved it that's one guy
that I was pushing for for for a lot of
years so I'm glad he got in why is it
we're not paying the linebacker feels
like the line linebacker and running
back the running well they're paying
linebackers more than they are running
backs I feel like they are um but these
you had to have a middle linebacker and
a running back back in the day you're
right yeah I I don't know why they're
devaluing runningbacks I understand
because there's a lot of guys that are
good at running back but mcaffry is
making a lot of money he's earning it um
it's just the game's changing right now
the running game is these little flare
screens or little po passes they throw
um they'll find a way to get three or
four yards on first or second down and
get in third and
short uh Aaron Rogers at this age trying
to come back from that injury he'll do
it he's awesome I mean in my opinion it
was momes and him as the two two of the
best three quarterbacks in the NFL uh
last year pretty much any any Year aon's
healthy he's one of the best in my
opinion but he'll come back you know I
think now he's more determined with the
way the season went for him and all the
hype that was surrounded the Jets and
look at that defense they're not I don't
think they're going to regress anytime
soon they're good you know I would want
to play quarterback for that team but
you know people talk about Mahomes and I
say Rogers was Mahomes before Mahomes in
my opinion agreed I mean you look at the
way the way he Maneuvers in the pocket
you know he moves he doesn't really
maneuver in the pocket to run he moves
up and down to get separation for his
receivers and kind of change Rush angles
for the D lineman but his accuracy is
unbelievable he doesn't make the the
crazy plays that Mahomes makes you know
they running around and throwing behind
his back or whatever he does but
accuracy wise Aeron you got to be top
two or three of all time I would think
but what's it like to be a defensive
player when the guy across from you
knows what you're going to do yeah
hopefully we make a play you know cuz
you know they're all the same all the
quarterbacks know most of them I'm sorry
know what defense you're in before they
snap the ball and Aaron was the best and
he would undress our defense all the
dummy calls the leg snap thing the fake
leg thing all this and then all of a
sudden the ball's not snapped and you're
you're showing your hand in defense we
were lucky enough on defense where we
could change our call as well when we
saw Aaron change we could change as well
we had most most of our guys are pretty
smart so we could be on the same page
but they know what you're doing you know
they're smarts hopefully you make a play
on defense and and get off the
but you're so close to that player and
you might not even get your hand on Aon
Rogers so you're just staring at him yep
you can did you say anything no well we
had we had some dummy calls I won't
repeat them on your show we had a lot of
good dummy calls that we would thought
fake him out you know cuz we they know
our checks they know we play them twice
a year so he knew exactly now why can't
you say them well they're not very nice
words some of them aren't nice words oh
yeah so You' yell out these words these
words that were some of them were some
of them were dummies and some of them
were actual checks and we had to Aon had
to figure out which was which you know
but did Rogers know what you were doing
you know he KN they all know you know
it's it's uh when our defense was simple
you know it was either cover two man or
his own Blitz it wasn't that it was that
hard to figure out we just we had good
players when you talk about Bears
linebackers obviously with yourself and
Mike single ter and the passing of dick
dick buus that hurt were you compared it
all to bukus at any point the media you
know obviously the media in Chicago when
I so I didn't know much about football
in Chicago before I got there I knew
Walter Peyton and the 85 Bears I didn't
know much about football before that um
but when you when I mov to middle
linebacker the media starts comparing
not comparing you but bringing up the
tradition you know Bill George dick
buckus Mike single ter and I was young I
didn't I like yeah those guys are great
but I'm I'm 22 years old I don't know
what you know what am I what I'm going
to be obviously now as it gone on we're
all in the Hall of Fame but I I always
appreciated buckus for he always called
it like he saw it didn't pull any
punches he was very whenever when I was
around he was always so witty and a
major smartass I love that like he just
said what he was thinking all the time
uh I think my second or third year I
helped the guy up off the ground after I
tackled him oh oh bad move by me he he
was in the newspaper of the media next
week saying that that's not okay you
know you're not supposed to help a guy
up after you tackle him but in my mind I
was like well it's not like I'm not
going to want to tackle him the next
play so I'll tackle him help him up hit
him the next play help him up does
didn't matter to me you know wasn't a
big deal but dig bucket did not like
that I remember Jim Brown whenever he'd
get hit he made it seem like you you
crushed him no oh the opposite like when
he get up he'd get up he'd be so slow
getting up okay and you'd think oh okay
like man they got him and then they give
him the ball like it's just it's it's
different man those guys are different
obviously but yeah dick buckus the world
is definitely a softer place without
dick buckus in it that dude was tough
man he uh he couldn't get away with
anything he got away with back in the
day when he righted in today's game and
your son's going to Notre Dame he is
yeah he committ to NRE Dame in uh in
June going to go play for Marcus there
norre Dame I'm excited about that he'll
go so he graduates High School in
December he's going to be an early and
rolly and go in January in what position
plays free safety so just like you back
in high school well yeah back in high
school he's a little bit more athletic
than I was believe it or not um yeah but
you return punch didn't you in high
school yeah but the my level of high
school is different than his level of
high school I played in New Mexico he
plays in a very good conference in
Arizona so they got big boy football
there I wasn't big boy big boy football
in high school would you so the you you
would have gotten nil money coming out
High School I may not have gotten any
how about that by the way isn't that
amazing how much these guys are getting
is your son going to get n money at
Notre Dame they do something for the for
every player on the team so yes they
will do that and then there's like a I
don't know how it works but I guess you
can earn Morey if you play good I think
you make a lot of money is that correct
basically uh you have a chance to make
at certain schools if you play well you
have a chance to make quite a bit of I
know the quarterback for noran does
pretty well Sam I know he does pretty
well one of their Corners is a true
freshman made over half a million bucks
I think doing nil so yeah what Sam make
I heard it's over the uh a million
dollars I heard but how do you know is
there like a sheet that says this is how
much this guy makes well I think you
have to report it though check your go
to the IRS that's how you know what they
really make well you got to check Sam
Hartman's tax return tax returns and
we'll see how much he made in nil money
but he's a good player yeah he had a
tough week last week sometimes have on
the Road Louisville they're good you
know top 25 now he's 24 I know it's
awesome good looking kid too I'm a big
fan of samart yeah but oh you know we've
had him we had him on after uh Notre
Dame played uh Navy in Dublin well that
was a cool game yeah you were there yeah
yeah yeah Will frell went with us nice I
like he's funny hey you're a movie star
yeah I am every Adam Sandler movie I can
expect to see you in it yeah no doubt
want me to get you in one I'm good I I
like to watch I appreciate it I'm a big
movie buff watching guy but I'm not I'm
not a very good actor have you been on a
TV show I was on According to Jim back
in the day like 2001 remember that Jimi
yeah was Entourage I'm sure you're on
Entourage multiple times right no no no
oh wow surprises me thought for sure
that one hurt a little bit that you
didn't make the appearance as yourself
but here's the thing yeah I don't like
playing me and I don't want to be on a
show that I might screw up that I like
gotcha how could you screw up I just
keep redoing it right it's just you know
some some people shouldn't be on shows
doing cameos gotcha that's that's all
okay I get it yeah like The Simpsons
they they're writing me into an episode
and I I I'm just playing an announcer
like Homer does a rock skipping uh
contest and I'm the announcer it's your
voice cuz it's great I get it very nice
that's all well people know it's you
because of your voice do you want to we
have a football field out there oh do
you want to hit Paulie you want some
more I thought we were both retired oh
you I know you said you're retired I
haven't hit anybody since that day so
I'm uh I'm good if you're good
iow as a no well you could you could
give us maybe a tech Techni or something
we could just do a let's just do a head
slap can we do that that was a great
technique by the way head slap was good
I know don't you wish you could do that
again I do it probably hurt my hand but
it feels like it's a great move well you
could bandage your hand up like Deacon
Jones did and just or all the forearm
pads and obviously you wear gloves but
you could just knock the crap out of
somebody it'd be great all right let me
give you uh the plug again uh Brian
joining us on behalf of LX ludex the
fastest most accurate Sports and trading
card scanner app they took the idea from
us so you know it's a good idea take a
picture identify and get the card values
instantly download for free he's Brian
irocker thank you for joining us Brian
thanks for having me back after this